l'école de l'étincelle figurent parmi
les 1931 bâtiments scolaires vétustes du
québec côté d ou e les problèmes de
fenêtres de plomberie et d'infestation
de souris font partie du quotidien du
personnel est arrivé cette année que
j'avais trouvé un élève avec un sachet
de poison au vert dans les mains et
heureusement il ya eu rien de grave qui
est arrivé
si tout va bien les élèves de cette
école spécialisée accueillant des élèves
âgés entre 4 et 12 ans ayant un trouble
du spectre de l'autisme pourront
déménager dans un nouvel établissement
en 2028
entre temps une relocalisation même
temporaire était impensable pour ces
jeunes qui peinent à cohabiter avec les
travaux onze élèves sont pas rentables
aux bruits font des crises les
comportements agressions augmentent de
toute relation s'ils sont vraiment pas
bien qu'à
l'école sophie-barat également côté eux
est la plus vieille du centre du service
scolaire de montréal est aussi son plus
important projet de rénovation et
d'agrandissement
le gouvernement du québec qui avertit
164 millions de dollars et le projet
tarde à se mettre en branle en ce que ça
viendrait jamais puis je pense des
parents dans le quartier indique son
humble décourager le gouvernement
legault est entré de rater sa cible
qu'il avait pourtant pris la peine
d'abaisser fortement en cours de mandat
l'objectif est d'obtenir
d'améliorer les choses pour que 1 22 23
on est au moins 50% du parc école qui
soit classée a b ou c on voudrait
augmenter sa bien plus vite mais on part
de tellement loin la moitié des écoles
primaires et secondaires du québec ont
été construites entre 1950 et 1970 pour
cet expert leur dégradation est
inévitable et je n'estime pas plutôt que
dans les années à venir on va on va
régler le problème de façon baguette
magique c'est un investissement d'au
moins 10 à c'est un projet de société
d'ici là c'est tout le milieu de
l'éducation qui attend la rentrée avec
appréhension
extrême je pensais moi ça me ferait il
si gabriel proulx radio canada montréal